how do i monetize me the book I want you
to teach me to think like you think
that's a goal of a thought leader I
don't like being the first to anything
okay believe nation we are live it's the
morning show ammonia how can I help you
YouTube social media what do I need to
know what's ahead because you have gone
through many transitions I'm sure so
what do I need to prepare for anything
that will help make a difference I know
you're still here because you managed to
stay ahead of all the curves that came
right so here's the thing like I don't
think I do a great job of staying ahead
of the curve if I'm being honest I don't
like being the first to anything I like
coming into something that's already
established and doing it better I think
there's always room for quality at the
top I think instead of worrying about
where the markets gonna be in five years
it's where is it right now and how can
you use your talents and energy and
abundance to create massive value even
look what I'm doing on Instagram I'm
late to the party like I'm very late to
the party Mr Graham YouTube I guess I
was early ish I wasn't the first
youtuber by any stretch
I hit YouTube probably at the right time
I hate Instagram late but I love it
because if you're good you can always
win there's always room for quality at
the top so I would be less focused on
where we're gonna be in ten years and
this is gonna be a 3d hologram of you
hugging people and thinking that you
know or VR you put on our lens and there
you are giving us a message in the
morning versus like how can you win
right now
how can you update YouTube game how can
you up here Instagram game social media
okay so with that then we're going to
shift okay which is actually the title
of the book my new book coming up how do
i monetize me the book because ideas the
the energy great at motivating people I
know I literally do that to people I
shift their mindset okay in conversation
how they see thing
okay your perception how do I get to
that point where I sell it
are you a coach yes you want to sell
coaching services absolutely
so one on one group coaching what oh so
then my goal would be to create a ton of
amazing content that then has people
writing in to say hey how do I hire you
to be my coach on in Surat on everything
so okay let's start with this how often
are you posting on Instagram and YouTube
three times a day on Instagram three
times the greater you post our story I
do a post the challenge I have I don't
make my post I guess personal enough
about what I do it's more the
motivational you know shifting okay
sort of stuff different ways to look at
things not so much my actual work I kind
of like oh my god I need to put that out
there that's when my introvert is my
social extrovert yeah yeah but my
introverts like I got even I did my
first book yeah I go I have to put that
in there hmm
yeah okay so lucky but see even three
times a day Instagram between soars and
posts you know one one written post and
then usually two stories are okay one
per day one story yeah great
how's YouTube once a day once a day
Tuesday to Friday
four times a week yeah okay I don't know
started and cycle that's fine awesome so
you're at the point where you're
actually producing content which is
great you can start paying attention to
your data to see like what format is
working they be trying different
experiments is it better for you like
did they like you when you're driving in
the car sharing advice or when you're
interviewing somebody or if you doing a
morning meditation or if you're doing an
afternoon shift or you know so you start
to get a sense of what series works
I would then start looking at how do I
incorporate my message of your books and
your coaching into the content and it
doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be guys I'm a coach
come hire me kind of yelling at people
you could do it in two ways one anytime
you're you're with a client that there's
a teachable lesson share that as a as a
video or a story so I was working the
client yesterday and you could change
the he/she you could change the you know
if it was if he's talking about his mom
you could make it a woman and her dad
like it doesn't matter you could change
the specific so it's not because the
lesson is still the lesson you help
somebody shift to tell me the story of
helping somebody shift even a lot of the
just before you came in I was posting on
my IG and most of the posts were
questions from people so they DME with a
question and and I'll make a video
response and I'll then share it with my
audience but it was never hey Julie no
here's right I would say the question
like where do I get my motivation from
okay I get my word from there right so
starting to share the stories of the
people who you've worked with right or
or people just writing in like saying
Jordan to me and she said this and
here's what you should do about that
Sandra right I again you could change
your names or a woman or a man or
whatever so that way I get to know that
you're a coach okay I get to know that
you have these services the other thing
I would recommend doing is having a free
yeah that's lots of time so you're a
thought leader I want you to teach me to
think like you think that's a goal of a
thought leader you should be able to
take your message and compress it down
into 15 seconds and blow it up to a one
hour keynote okay if you're speaking at
some event and everything in between 15
seconds a minute five minutes 20 minutes
right so whenever I'm doing speeches it
they say okay haven't you got 25 minutes
so you've got 45 minutes so you have an
hour okay all right fair enough all of
the parts of shifting can be soundbites
or can be a giant thing but the next
thing I would do so yes trying to share
the stories of people that you're
interacting with and seeing the
first a time coaching here's what she's
going through and here's how I helped
the other thing I thought I would have
some kind of free giveaway so if you
have a shift shift for success seven
step I know I have tea right so like if
you have a five step whatever it has
seven bonus PDF but then they could
download so you use your social as a
lead magnet so anybody who's interested
in getting your five-step process it's a
free you make a free bonus PDF that then
they put in their email and they get the
bonus and now you have you can send them
emails and updates about your coaching
services it's pretty easy I use Aweber
awwe BER Aweber but but MailChimp and
all of them do the same thing in the
first you just go did she call
autoresponder or follow-up sequence the
first one is the the bonus hate ammonia
thank you so much for downloading my PDF
here it is
you know remember to Papa whatever your
intro messages then I would follow up
with five emails talking about shift so
it's n an S email in each email and on
and what it means right okay I'm at the
bottom of each email could be and this
is all automatic right like you set it
up once and then anytime somebody
downloads PDF for the next whether it's
once a day for seven days or it's every
week for seven weeks so you have your
your first one's gonna be the PDF then
you have five individual emails which at
the bottom you could put a if you want
to learn the whole thing buy my book
shift on sale blink at Amazon wherever
people can buy it so it's a soft pitch
at the end of each of your emails like a
little PS at the bottom if you want the
whole thing by the book and then after
they've gone to the sequence the last
one is the pitch email for the book you
mean like I can actually do it
you should be able to do it you get one
link on Instagram right so you can put a
get my free shift PDF for how to shift
your life and 5 simple steps download
below and then the link is the link to
sign up to get the PDF okay well I guess
you answered that one so it's better to
you want to do live videos with myself
because my question one was do I it's
better to do live videos with me but I
do want to do that based on your answer
because I want to sell my service who I
am let people see me cuz good why are
they gonna buy me if they don't know
much about me I mean they can see my
content but it doesn't really show me
it's chicken pictures instead of
recording record videos oh yeah like
you're so good on camera you should be
doing video you have such an energy that
you can't get from just a picture okay
yeah all right one minute videos on
Instagram max if you do 30 seconds is
great all right anytime you're feeling
heightened emotion film haha like
yesterday what was yesterday ah that was
tough day okay last year okay head my
book launch okay November 1st but I love
some movin okay in the rain it was
raining like this okay but I wasn't
moving into a home okay so my kids and I
lived in a hotel for a little bit okay
until we got a house after so it's like
so yeah well what was yesterday though
just remembering yeah just remember and
I find when I have is like the birth of
my kids or whatever those times there's
just some things like the emotions that
I was going through then just somehow
it's like I'm reliving it yeah so it was
just you know heightened day but turned
out good I'm driving him thinking okay
who can I talk to because people now
have gotten used to me where they know
my energy yeah so if I call somebody and
I go like if my friend yesterday she
called me she goes you don't sound
so you found heavy I'm like no I'm good
yeah so I'm driving I call this guy in
Atlanta yeah hey Avery and he goes oh
today's my birthday okay good
so I made his day yeah which kind of
lifts me up yeah because I do like
bringing value to others you know having
that impact on their life so I think
when I find myself in these plates or
I'm like you wanna I wanna hide yeah
because it's very hard to encourage yes
I'm feeling it yeah so yes and no you
know I think people don't want to learn
from the perfect person if they see you
and you're always happy you're always
energetic it's like well I I can't be
that you can't you don't want to learn
from the perfect person and so I would
encourage you know you're not down every
day hopefully they're like that might be
the greatest post of all time if you if
you made a video either even before your
friend like if you made a video to say
guys I'm feeling low energy today yeah
it happens to me too
a year ago today I had to move out of my
home and move into a hotel and I didn't
know where my life was going at that
point on the anniversary I'm just
struggling dealing with the emotions I'm
super grateful that I made the shift and
now you know I'm here but today I'm
feeling the weight of of what my life
used to be like and I just want to
remind you that like I went through
tough times too when you can get through
it right and then if you then meant to
make your friend and you said it's my
birthday that could be another video
guys you know what earlier this morning
I was feeling low now I met my friend
from from Atlanta and this his birthday
and I made his day
and I just realized when you serve you
feel better okay so if you're feeling
low just find someone to serve it's sort
of looking at Instagram environment the
captions always matter and if you're a
writer that's great because a lot of
people's the captions are bad because
they don't know how to write so that's a
that's a awesome advantage you have but
you're so great
there's so much energy that comes out of
you that that's like you're cheating
yourself ticker right look you're
cheating yourself
I you have a really strong asset that
other people don't have that you should
be leveraging so you could do both like
you can make the video and that'll be
more of an expression and the words
won't be perfect but it's heartfelt and
and it's gonna hit me because it's
emotional whether it's gratitude whether
it's sorrow whether its abundance
whether it's shift you know highs and
lows there'll be more highs and lows but
but sharing the low make somebody
connect with you people say you have to
be authentic be authentic but what does
that mean well authenticity is share
anything you're actually most scared to
share that's being authentic that's
what's actually gonna connect people to
you because if you have your perfect
armor on all the time people can't
penetrate it but if you know that even
you you you cry and you get down
sometimes and you are we're looking for
your next shift sometimes you don't
always have it all figured out but you
still have the courage to get up every
day and go tackle the bear you know
you're still moving forward that's an
inspiration so your your video will be
imperfect words but amazing energy
because you're being present with the
emotion that you're feeling where then
you can write captions which are then
the perfect words that you want to
express why what what are you afraid of
I guess just being one a rebel just
being out there
in my life it may look like the perfect
world but I have to do so much alone
yeah you know you we decide people to be
there hey I'm here for you but when you
pick up the phone and you call I'm sorry
not right now
yeah you know I can't do that so I just
grew up knowing what am i able to do for
myself by myself yeah and and I do that
yeah and then you know that's it so I
just make what I'm able to do for me
work yep and not expecting and it's if
anything else come oh my goodness yeah
it's bonus it's great I celebrate and I
enjoy yeah but I don't have the
expectation yep because you know you've
been let down so many times that's like
that's the thing that you need to share
without calling anybody yet without
saying like my sister my family they're
gonna take it anyway
I'm even with doing my shift yeah I've
had people send me messages shipped on
YouTube yeah but if they connect yeah
what's that
no it was not about you yeah that's
several attacked yes all right so yeah
that's the thing though ultimately that
people will love you for and feel
because you want people to see
themselves in you and by you getting out
and being ahead of it and and sharing
that part then it gives permission to
other people to feel like they're not
alone as well so that builds a stronger
connection and those are the people
gonna buy your book if you want to learn
how to use Instagram to sell t-shirts
and other products check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there hey man what's up kid none
much
oh man this is a beautiful thing mr.
ever come back this is beautiful man I
never would have seen this coming